The Kurds live across the border area spanning
Iran, Iraq, Turkey, and Syria.
They say that they're the largest people today
without a nation, and that may very well be
true.
They thought that they could have a country
in the wake of World War I, but at the end,
it was denied to them by the great powers,
by oil interests, and so forth.
In recent decades, the Kurds have suffered
tremendous oppression under a variety of dictators,
especially in Iraq where Saddam Hussein famously
used chemical weapons against them.
They've also led a bloody, bloody insurgency
in Turkey, a group that's called the PKK or
the Kurdistan Workers Party.
That insurgency has claimed the lives of more
than 40,000 people between 1984 and the present,
and we've recently seen an upswing of violence
there.
The important thing to remember about the
Kurds, however, is while they claim that they're
one people, in reality, they're divided among
many, many different political groups.
And often times, they spend just as much time
fighting each other as fighting others.
Is there room for another nation-state in
the Middle East?
Should we be in the business of redrawing
borders?
Let us know in the comments, and let us know
what other topics you want us to cover in
sixty seconds.